[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
madden football is the home of super
bowl 56 and this historic matchup is
brought to you by ea sports it's the
patriots and the seahawks coming up next
it's the national football league
presented by ea sports
tonight it's all on the line we play for
the lombardi trophy guys it'll be the
afc champion new england patriots
taking on the nfc champions
planning garden alongside charles davis
and the patriots charles what more can
you say last year tom brady moves on
wins the super bowl in tampa the
patriots struggle home to a seven and
nine finish and everyone says ah this is
it dynasty is finally over but they turn
right around win the afc title and now
make their record 12th appearance in a
super bowl and i think you have to just
applaud what this organization has done
whether you like them or not because you
hit on it in a big way
most of us assumed that that run was
over but they've retooled
brought in some extra players changed a
few of their philosophies and here they
are again competing for another super
bowl crowd meanwhile for the seahawks
they are back again in the big game it's
their fourth appearance but all coming
since the year 2000 charles they've been
in it three times total right lost two
prior right lost once in detroit to the
pittsburgh steelers remember mike
holmgren was the head coach of that team
and then they lost that heartbreaker to
the new england patriots when russell
wilson was picked off but the win oh it
was magnificent that was back in the new
york new jersey metropolitan area super
bowl 48 and remember they just rolled
over the denver broncos and peyton
manning in that one they'd like to have
that kind of performance again in this
one
from a yard or two deep here comes a
return yeah he brought down cheyenne to
20 so the decision to bring it out of
the end zone not a good one
here come the seahawks time for that
offense and quarterback russell wilson
to go to work and he comes in off of a
tremendous game in the nfc championship
round two weeks ago this has been a team
all season long that's really taken
their identity from their quarterback
and he's been very vocal in days leading
up to this game that he believes that
this is their time and he's going to do
all he can to will them to a super bowl
win
[Music]
[Applause]
so from inside the 20 here's first and
10 at the 18.
there's wilson
and his first look is incomplete
i think he's got to be careful not to
force anything into coverage right there
there weren't really any throwing lanes
but the best part for him he's got
second and third down to fall back on
[Music]
after the incomplete pass here now is
second and ten
now wilson
and this one incomplete
too much contact hold on to that one and
it's
[Applause]
and to me one thing's for sure when
you're the underdogs and you're playing
on the road you absolutely have to get
takeaways you've got to get the ball
from them yeah win that turnover battle
gonna be key they didn't get one there
but you get the feeling they keep making
plays like that they might just get a
few yeah once you get one defensive
teams think they come in bunches
on third down wilson
it's caught baldwin and he is going to
have a seahawks first down as they're
able to get the third down conversion
so he turned to a trusted familiar face
in that third down situation it paid off
yeah go to your veteran receiver in that
spot so you can't underestimate him when
he's on the field defensively make sure
you know where he is because he
understands how to get open in key
situations
line of scrimmage the 31 now on first
and 10.
they go play action now wilson
this is caught by tay
and he's taken down right at the 45-yard
line
[Applause]
the goal for any offense versus his own
defense
find the holes where guys are available
and put the ball in the receiver before
any defender can step up and fill it
they did it well there perfectly
executed crossing route
[Applause]
so into pat's territory now here's first
and ten at the 45-yard line
here's wilson to throw
flush to his and he can't find a
receiver and he's brought down
the sack recorded it's a loss of five
[Applause]
[Music]
we always talk about low man wins in the
running game for an offensive lineman
versus defensive lineman it's
essentially the same thing in pass
protection get lower than that defensive
lineman so you can keep your balance and
keep them away from your guy trying to
throw the football
gotta assume this defense will be
charging again here it's second at 15.
from midfield now here's wilson
throwing right and that's complete
and he's out of bounds as he gets this
down to the 45.
well if you do read man coverage brandon
the drag route's a pretty good one to
run against it because you're running
away from people on them
[Music]
out of the gun here's wilson
he's going to air this out deep for
harvin and i think that one might have
been intercepted but he will be ruled
out of bounds so this will go only as
incomplete
an early message that this secondary is
going to be tested because even though
it fell incomplete it almost felt like a
warning shot to get things going
the seahawks send out their punter as he
should be able to pin him back deep here
with his first pun
and that one hits at the seven but
bounds into the end zone and that'll be
a touch back
so here come the patriots now on offense
they will be let out by their now 44
year old quarterback playing in his 22nd
nfl season
unbelievable the great tom brady and
he's been sensational all season long
but he saved his best work for the
playoffs leading his guys to the afc
championship a couple of weeks ago
and now he knows what lies ahead he's
gonna need to play a near perfect four
quarters of football to get his guys to
the finish line
brady and the patriots now first and ten
at their own 20-yard line
the drive starts with the hand off to
blow and he'll work this forward for
about three and second down
yeah i don't know if it's exactly a
win-win but if you're on offense you'll
take that kind of a run all right it was
kind of stacked up found a little bit of
yardage and frankly they're pretty close
to staying on schedule on offense the
playbook is still open for the
coordinator
on second and seven brady it's a slant
to gronkowski
[Applause]
there it is partner brady degron their
first connection in the game you think
those two often in sync
i don't think there's any question about
it and look we know gronk has a whole
lot of fun but he's deadly serious about
his football as is tom brady two great
competitors two fantastic players
brady now on first down and that's off
the mark incomplete you saw the coaches
tell us all the time those scouting
reports aren't just to use up paper guys
well nowadays you know we're watching a
computer screen right they scouted this
team very well know that they like to
use the running backs in the passing
game they covered that play successfully
so after the incompletion on first now
second and ten
now brady
then he finds gronk
and able to break one tackle but then
quickly brought down but a nice little
gain
that'll leave him with a third and two
coming up they got eight yards there i
know exactly what's going to be said
about that play from the defensive
perspective what's that that's why i
tell all you guys we need more than one
tackler to the ball he broke the first
tackle luckily enough there are more
people there to get him down
on third down
yeah he will be very close to a first
down but i see the close fist to the
referee and that means fourth down only
two yards and it'll be a punt on their
opening possession
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
no score after one on ea sports
start of the second quarter and it's the
patriots in control of the football
[Applause]
the patriots send out their punter as
he's on to kick it away
and a nice special teams job here this
is going to be down inside the 10 at the
seven yard line
so they'll play the field position game
here is a very nice punt is going to pin
them back yeah it's almost like watching
a game of tennis or do you prefer ping
pong you know back and forth like that
that definitely was excellent wasn't it
seattle's offense coming back onto the
field ready for their second drive
they're gonna have to go at least 50 60
yards here if they want to ensure that
they don't have to punt the ball like
they did last time yeah so what you're
saying is we're not playing to just get
out of the shot of your own goal line
right you're playing to make sure the
punter doesn't see the field again so
it's not picking up a couple of first
downs he won't pick up five or six first
downs and make sure you move the ball
into their territory
they start the drivewood lynch and he
will take this up to about the eight
yard line
just a yard on the pickup there and
it'll bring up a second and nine that
play reminded me a lot of a former
teammate of mine we used to call him the
trash man his ability to sift through
traffic and make plays was uncanny and
that's exactly what you want from your
mike linebacker the run only got a yard
here's second and nine
from the shotgun wilson
looking middle and it's incomplete
defensively charles they continue to
really limit this offense as far as
yardage goes yeah you're exactly right
they've been assignment sound staying in
their lanes keeping proper leverage and
communicating well too
after an incomplete pass on second down
that'll leave him trying to convert on
third and nine
from the gun it's wilson
got a man over the middle and it's
complete
he is going to have a seahawks first
down as they're able to get the third
down conversion
they were backed up to start the drop
how about that aggressiveness firing it
down field right away nice job there
getting out towards what would have been
their normal starting position
[Applause]
[Music]
first down the run with lynch and he's
going to take this ahead for right
around three yards but no more than that
second down
not a lot of running room there not a
place to make a cut and kind of exit out
because they had everything bottled up
looked to me like the linemen were
taking on their blocks really well and
giving up no creases three yards on that
last carry here's second and seven
from the pistol they run with lynch
and he's going to be met at the
scrimmage and taken down
no gain on the play as we have reached
the two-minute warning
two minutes on the clock in the second
quarter of this super bowl
[Applause]
[Music]
a reminder coming up at intermission
we'll get highlights in the super bowl
from jonathan coachman of the crew in
orlando for our ea sports halftime
report
open man is miller he's got it and he is
going to have a seahawks first down as
they're able to get the third down
conversion
and that's well executed there on third
down and i love the confidence that they
had to let their tight end try and find
some space in the middle of the field
right in their quarterback's line of
vision and qb's love to make that easy
throw and they hooked up there for a
first down
eluding the pressure right wilson hit
it's loose it's out fumble and it's
picked up by the patriots and they'll
set up shop in enemy territory at the
45-yard line
we know he's got the speed to get down
field charles but there's the negative
side a little loose with the football
that time and that's normal especially
when you have his type of talents
because you feel like you're into the
open field
and maybe you don't feel the people who
are around you or closing in
all quarterbacks have to do extra ball
security drills with the way the game is
played now because defenses they attack
the football as much as they attack the
runner
[Applause]
now after the fumble recovery it's brady
and it's caught here amendola and
brought down but able to get it to their
30-yard line
[Applause]
had to put that ball in there with a
little extra zip but he put it right
where it needed to be yeah that little
extra pace that he had on the pass that
required a little extra concentration
for him didn't it ball can get on you
pretty quick in that matter and he
handled it well and picked up the first
down
creeping up on a minute to play in this
first half
now the patriots gonna use one of their
timeouts
as they'll stop it with just over a
minute to go before halftime
[Applause]
[Music]
so first and ten now from the
30. working from the gun it's brady
to the right side and he's got edelman
and they move this all the way down to
the nine
now the patriots will use the second of
their timeouts as they get the stoppage
with a little over 50 seconds to go in
the first half
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
their chance for the first score of this
super bowl here's first and goal
now brady
there's washington touchdown new england
and the patriots on just two plays have
taken the lead
and that touchdown gives them a
touchdown lead before they attempt the
extra point what a great way to end the
half yeah great job to put themselves in
front and now see on the sideline
special teams defense scrambling saying
we want to preserve this for the final
moments of this second quarter now
steven goszkowski on for the extra point
and he gets it to make it seven nothing
patriots
the long touchdown pass gets him six on
a very very tidy to play drive that time
[Applause]
set now to kick this one away and off it
goes
from a couple yards deep he'll bring it
out of the end zone and he had no room
to run as he's tackled down inside the
20.
[Music]
the seahawks going to take over now late
in this first half and within trailing
there is still enough time to try to
string a few plays together maybe get
into field goal range
[Music]
so from inside the 20 here's first and
10 at the 18.
wilson
caught right side tape
now the seahawks gonna use the first of
their timeouts as they'll stop it with
40 seconds remaining in this first half
ball up to the 35 now as they come up on
first and 10.
now it's wilson
yeah a quick throw here that's complete
and he'll go out of bounds and looks
like right at the 40.
they'll contain him to just four second
down
[Music]
now wilson
throw left side complete that's lynch
and he'll be out of bounds up near the
45 at the 44.
that might feel like a little bit of a
lost opportunity there for the offense
because the defense brought pressure
that time and sometimes against that you
can get out to your running back and it
could turn into a big gain downfield but
what a nice job they did getting to him
quickly and holding him to a short game
firing quickly here and that's complete
and taking it across midfield and just
shy of the 40.
now the seahawks call the second of
their three timeouts as they'll stop it
with 25 seconds to go here in half
number one
this offense finding its legs now here's
another first and ten
throwing is wilson
he'll dump it off complete to lynch
so five yards here five on the play
and that'll bring up second down
and offensively they'll take the timeout
with six seconds left in the second
quarter
[Music]
so on second down the field goal unit is
on here as they try to get three before
half
this from 54 yards away
and his kick is good
and they are on the board but still
trailing it's 7-3
so they do get three points but that's
now three drives with only the three
points not a ratio that's going to win
you many ball games not at all brandon
and think about it this way we all know
payoff is the key right and wouldn't we
love to have the concession on every
t-shirt that's been printed in football
that says finish on it because that's
the mantra everywhere gotta be able to
finish drives put points on the board
so barring a touch back this likely the
final act of the half as the kick is
away
and not wanting to risk anything here
late in the half he'll just take a knee
and they'll bring the football out to
the 25.
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he'll take the knee in the final couple
seconds will tick by in this first half
so we've reached halftime here in the
super bowl as we are off to orlando now
to check in with jonathan coachman and
our ea sports halftime report coach okay
brandon thanks very much and welcome
everyone to this abridged version of the
ea sports halftime report first things
first though let's get a check on the
next-gen stats from that first half for
new england and it was a tricky half to
figure out numbers-wise they've got the
lead but you figure they're definitely
talking about ways to get this passing
game back on track
meanwhile for the seahawks they had a
little more success than their
counterparts did in the passing game as
evidenced by the numbers there
all right coach thanks yeah both teams
likely to make some changes in what's
been a closely fought battle to this
point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these two teams sat through a longer
than usual 30-minute wait but we're back
in action here in this super bowl
this will come out to the 25 as lewis
gonna opt to not return it
the patriots taking over to start
quarter number three
we have not seen much on offense from
either side these last few drives it has
been a struggle hasn't it totally and
you're thinking to yourself right now if
you're on offense trying to get things
figured out okay we self scout every
week in our game plan
how many things do we do at certain
times what are our tendencies time to go
to some of those tendency breakers and
try and create some offense they always
have those in their back pocket don't
they you have to and if you don't keep
abreast of what you're doing you lock
into a rhythm and make it easy for the
opposition looking for tendency breakers
right now and he'll be upended at the
28-yard line just a three-yard gain
there
look all any running back wants is a
little bit of room a little bit of space
in order to maneuver but he also
understands how difficult it is for his
offensive line up front so if they give
him any space he realizes his job to
make more out of it than what they give
him picks up three on that carrot
they faked the handoff now brady
looking for element and he hits him it's
complete but he's gonna be out of bounds
right at midfield
and defensively they were in zone
coverage there do you have to be a
little careful you're losing playing
against a good quarterback like he is to
not play too much zone yeah you have to
be careful about how much time you're
giving up i think it's a good point you
just brought up so maybe if you still
want to play zone you go to a zone blitz
game and you can drop anyone out of your
defensive front defensive end defensive
tackle it doesn't matter you just
exchange someone to bring more pressure
towards the quarterback and still try
and cover downfield
now a play fake brady
then he finds edelman again yeah he's
got this to the 30 before being taken
down
it's taking a while for this offense to
get going a little creaky at the start
but they're oiled up now a nice throw
there and they're really putting
together a good drive
[Applause]
[Music]
so first and ten now from the 30.
from the gun it's brady
over the middle it's amendola
and they'll get him down after a pickup
of eight second and two
i know many people like to throw to the
tight end maybe in a little flexed out
position because he creates mismatches
with his size but slot receivers do the
same thing
again they'll throw with brady
it's caught outline amendola i love how
emphatic you are with that call because
that's exactly what i was thinking wide
open in the flat give him a ball that he
can use to get up field with not just
catch and go over the sideline
brady gonna try and throw on third down
and they're gonna get him he's sacked
back around
[Applause]
[Music]
just absolutely outguess yourself third
in inches they decide not to run the
ball you end up seeing the end result
the end result was not good they elect a
pass and it backfires
so on fourth down brady will yield to
goskowski for the field goal try from
the right hand this from 45 yards away
goskowski's kick is good
and they push the lead up to a touchdown
now at 10 to 3.
looking at it from a defensive
perspective that keeps the deficit very
very manageably and all things
considered not a bad job on the
defensive side i would say that you've
pointed out something pretty good right
there and that is you actually have both
sides happy with that exchange you know
happy and quote of course
one team hey we've kept kept it within
range the other side saying hey we put
points on the board and did stretch out
the lead let's see how this one turns
out yeah still bottom line though three
points for the opening drive of the
third quarter
that is the kickoff unit as they run up
and send this one away
here's harvard
and it's a pretty good return here so
get this up to the 29.
[Music]
now we'll see what this seahawks offense
has in store with their first possession
of the second half and their deficit a
little wider now than it was at halftime
following the field goal a moment ago
but the goal is still the same because
you know they want to come out establish
a rhythm in the second half and get
going make no mistake about it though
kicking field goals not in their game
plan they need to get involved in the
end zone
wilson the seahawks take over now first
and ten just shy of the 30.
off the play fake wilson
now he'll escape to his right and he'll
protect himself at the end here as he
winds up getting pretty decent yardage
he'll get 10 there all on his own but
it'll be second down
well he did a nice job keeping his eyes
downfield waiting for someone to get
open but once the pressure forced his
eyes down to see the rush it was time to
make a break for it a good gain on first
has him set up with second and just a
couple of inches now from the 29.
here's wilson
they'll set up the screen to lynch
and he'll get up to the 43-yard line
the other day when he's watching the
game
trying to watch an nfl game and trying
to account for their passing game that's
difficult and just when you think you
get everything covered here comes a back
out of the backfield in this case he
picks up a first down
[Applause]
on first down
it's lynch and he's gonna take this
ahead for right around three yards but
no more than that
second down
[Music]
one quarter remains here in the super
bowl we'll return with more after this
this is the nfl and it's on e a sports
back now here on ea sports
it's the seahawks with possession of the
football but they do trail here to begin
quarter number four
[Applause]
coming up on second and seven
to throw is wilson
he completes it to take
[Applause]
the drive continues as they search for a
tying touchdown here's first and 10.
now wilson
he's able to find miller
touchdown seahawks
a great play there
46 yards and the seahawks are an extra
point away from tying
but we are set up for a fantastic finish
now a fourth quarter touchdown here
we're an extra point away from a thai
football game and i know they're
thinking about possibly going for two
but i'd go ahead and kick this one and
just get it back to level
now still down one here's an utterly
critical extra point attempt here
and it is good there were about 70 000
people about to turn blue from holding
their breaths
but it's good and this super bowl is
tied
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all level now at 10 a piece as the kicks
away
now lewis selects to return it
and he'll be brought down shy of the 20s
so the decision to bring it out of the
end zone not a good one
out comes the new england offense to see
what they can do this time
and this super bowl has been as good as
advertised probably one of the best that
we've seen in recent memory all even
here in this fourth quarter
[Applause]
[Music]
so brady and the pants take over first
and ten at their own 18.
they'll begin here with bloom
and he'll take this one up to about the
23.
five yards on the carry good pickup on
first down that's a really nice tough
run inside and they gain five yards on
it and be frank about it most offenses
don't expect to get five yards on a play
call like that so when they do
they go back to their huddle with a
little pep in their steps they're
starting to think that they're starting
to dominate the line of scrimmage
a second down run with lewis and that
one blown up quickly as he's going to be
stopped before he could even get started
that's a big loss of three and it brings
up third down so statistically
both of these offenses have a rough time
getting a running game going but boy
what a nice play there defensively
tackling behind the line but you're
right you look at the numbers
neither side looks on track in the
ground game
one of the bigger plays in the game thus
far the crowd getting into it as we come
up on a big third down
now flags come in looks like one of the
patriots might have moved
the crowd's not doing that o-line any
favors home field advantage is really
kicking in making it very difficult for
them to hear the snap count
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
possibly a turning point big play coming
this is third and long
here's brady
the defense rising to the challenge
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
getting down to the good stuff all tied
with two minutes remaining audie sports
[Applause]
[Music]
so the patriots with a football as we
get your reset and they're looking at
fourth down now in this tie ball game
so from their own end zone here this
kicks away
oh able to avoid him
a 45-yard punt for their only return and
the seahawks have great field position
to start this drive they take over on
the short side of the field
seattle now ready to march onto the
field
and they'll be looking to build off of a
nice drive last time a drive that really
relied on the
quarterback making good decisions
distributing the ball well distributing
it accurately keeping it away from
danger a really nicely run drive but now
the defense what adjustments do they
need to make in the passing game pass
rush
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
wilson's throw pulled in by tate that
he'll go down but not before getting
this inside the 30.
[Applause]
but they picked up a little bit of
yardage there and now
in this situation should be in no hurry
to run a play really fast let the clock
wind down
they'll run on first down it's lynch
escapes the defender and he'll take this
into the end zone now hold on here we do
have a flag down
so let's see what this is about
[Applause]
no doubt about it and this is where you
make a great movie scene right go in
rally the team okay we lost poinsettias
get it back and go out and score again
can he get it done
on first down they're going option left
and he'll be brought down inside the 20
at the 19.
now the patriots gonna use one of their
timeouts as they'll talk things over
prior to this upcoming second down play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
give the lynch from the shotgun and
they'll bring him down at the 13-yard
line
now the patriots will use the second of
their timeouts
as they get the stoppage with 65 seconds
remaining
[Applause]
from the 13 now they work on first and
ten
[Applause]
on the ground it's lynch
and he will score touchdown seattle
a 13-yard touchdown run
and the seahawks have taken the lead
[Applause]
hey that score our respect deserves our
excitement but i'm looking at the clock
and i'm thinking there's a long way to
go in this one ideally they would have
liked to milk a little bit more time off
now on the other sideline you start to
get the crew together and say
this is what we practice the two-minute
drill for right yeah you hope you've
been in that situation before and if you
have it you just have the confidence hey
let's go down there and get this thing
done but boy that's a big score right
there to give him the advantage
extra point right down the middle and
that makes it a 17-10 score
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and he'll take it a yard or so past the
20 call it the 21.
brady and the patriots now trailing
17-10 a little under a minute to go
and they have to have a touchdown to
level this super bowl as they come up on
first down
[Applause]
[Applause]
back to throw brady
throwing left side he's got drawn
complete
and they're going to get this beyond the
40 before he's taken down
jude's first down gotta hurry yeah now
they have to get up there get set and
then spike it
[Applause]
clock rolling here about to hit 30
seconds
brady to throw
wide open gronkowski
and he's brought down
the patriots will take their third and
final timeout as the clock will stop
with an even 20 seconds left to go
[Applause]
the drive continues as they search for a
tying touchdown here's first and 10.
now brady
they'll let this go for the end zone
well this one almost intercepted
had
[Music]
they took their shot for the end zone
almost cost him and he made the right
play there knocking it away but boy it
looked like he had a chance to come down
with the football if he does that this
thing is over instead he leaves him out
there with another chance
an incomplete pass on first down that
leads to a second and ten
[Applause]
to throw is brady
that should have been intercepted but he
cannot corral it and that is a lifeline
there with third down coming up
[Applause]
[Music]
so back to back in completions and that
has him staring at a third and 10.
he's back to throw
gonna air it out deep for gronkowski and
it's incomplete so their final drive
comes up empty and with that the ball
game is over and the seahawks are the
class of the nfl seattle wins the super
bowl
[Music]
and when this moment comes i think you
look back at all the blood sweat and
tears the off-season the workouts
training camp week one two three all
building up now to say you're a super
bowl champion it's worth it it certainly
is and rarely
do we have a team to hoist the lombardi
trophy they didn't have their share of
bumps along the way didn't have to face
some adversity in the journey and now
they get to just enjoy it and revel in
it and all off season they'll be signing
their autographs with super bowl
champion underneath it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you